movie about a former spy played by a
former Bond starring a former Bond girl
am I the only one who finds this odd the
November man is directed by Roger
Donaldson and stars Pierce Brosnan as
the title character and it comes out in
August the last film of the summer this
movies about a former spy who's drawn
back into the game when someone he
really cares about is hurt by someone
that he actually trained so for that
reason he has to go back into this field
try to figure out who's behind it while
also getting revenge for what happened
to the person that he really cared about
now Roger Donaldson has directed movies
in the past that I thought were pretty
good the bank job I thought was one of
Jason Statham's best films he also
directed Pierce Brosnan the 1997 film
Dante's Peak believe it or not and when
I heard about Pierce Brosnan returning
as a spy I got to be honest a little bit
of nostalgia was going through my veins
at that point that being said this movie
ain't really that good unfortunately and
the main problem with this movie is that
it actually doesn't seem to get started
until about halfway through and that's
the honest truth there are so many
different spy cliches throughout this
movie for mainly the first half where it
just is like are you gonna do anything
different is there gonna be anything
different or cool about this movie or is
it just gonna be a whole bunch of people
walking away from slow-motion explosions
over and over again but then they were
in the halfway point the movie kind of
showed itself and towards the third act
the movie really showed itself and I was
like okay why didn't you why didn't you
do stuff like this from the beginning
this is different this is cool but it
took so long to get to that point that I
had already checked out I was already
completely uninterested in the movie and
it was just sort of like okay this is
very disposable very mediocre action
entertainment Brosnan is fine in this
movie he could play this role in his
sleep he's basically an older more
hardened and more sad James Bond has a
bit more of a human element to him so
his character is cool I can see why he'd
want to play this character it's a nice
role for him it's just the film itself
is so completely uninteresting until
almost the end of the movie where you
start to realize where certain things
were going and certain puzzle pieces
start to make sense and then it's like
okay I'm kind of interested in this
final act but everything up until then
was so run-of-the-mill and so incredibly
cliched you could see like every single
plot point from every single spy movie
ever
made was his all rolled into one the
character that pierce brosnan trains is
played by luke Bracy i found his
character very wood and very dull not
much to him it's a really interesting
idea the trainer and the trainee are now
pitted against each other and the drama
that could have been had from that isn't
really had except for maybe one or two
scenes we even kind of touch like okay
that was really cool why didn't the rest
of the movie feel like that olga
kurylenko shoot man i don't know i
thought she did a pretty good job in the
movie she was good as her character and
once you realized certain things about
her character there's a lot of sympathy
for her character and the film takes on
a completely different meaning
it's just that until then nothing really
happens that's different from any other
spy movie we've seen a thousand died I
know how I got whispery there but the
November man is a movie that could have
been a lot better and it's almost like
the filmmakers realized it could have
been a lot better when there was like 20
minutes left in the movie but up until
then it was all very much the same as
everything else you've seen before I'm
gonna give the November man a see Pierce
Brosnan was good at playing a role he
could have played in his sleep but the
writing and the directing could have
been so much stronger well guys the
summer of 2014 is officially over guys
what's your favorite movie of the summer
what's the movie this summer that you
went back and watched over and over
again you saw it multiple times in
theaters let me know below I'm curious
to know what you guys think of that guys
thank you so much for watching and as
always if you liked this you can click
right here and get stuck nice
[Music]
Oh